no I both had the they had the idea that
you know I should stay in a given
University only five years and I stayed
I mean after being in Europe I went to
illinois and was there for five years
and I went to Columbia was there for
five years then I was at Harvard for
five years then I actually moved to
Paris and my feeling was that it was
very good to get a new environment to
start new problems and completely
different problems like the first five
years at the University of Illinois you
I mentioned I developed this equation I
was focused on nuclear magnetic
resonance which was a new technique in
chemistry and I felt that the
theoretical approaches could give
insights that people didn't have because
it wasn't sort of worked out and then
when I went to Columbia I started
working on chemical reactions and when I
went to Harvard I started working on
biological systems and I think that well
as having a new environment and starting
something new makes it most likely or
more likely maybe the fair answer that
you'll really discover something and you
know I from any I'd get invited to go to
meetings that discuss you know what I'd
sort of stopped doing and you know and
the people are doing interesting things
but for me I sort of have the feeling
yes I know what's going on and it
doesn't have the same excitement of
course being a professor having students
you can still be sort of working in the
old area so you don't sort of suddenly
stopped publishing and people wonder
what's going on while you're developing
ideas as to what they're doing is new I
think it's right if you want to continue
to be creative you have to go into
something that you don't understand
otherwise at least for me it isn't very
exciting